[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben ich zeige euch heute
einzelner lieblingsrezepte wenn man das
rezept nennen darf denn ihr braucht nur
drei zutaten für diese leckeren pralinen
und alles was wir benötigen sind kinder
- ich nehme natürlich die light variante
denn ich liebe kinder bereit ist gehen
aber auch die normalen außerdem noch ein
wenig doppel ram frischkäse und weiße
kuvertüre hier kommt die variante falls
ihr kein mixa zu hause habt dann nehmt
euch einfach die kinderpornos zu drückt
sie mit der gabel bis ihr ja so eine art
brei bekommt und dann gebt ihr den
frischkäse mit dazu verrät das
miteinander
wundert euch nicht das hier ist nur ein
drittel der zutaten denn das zeige ich
euch nur um zu demonstrieren dass ihr
nicht immer ein mixa benötigt
die andere alternative wäre dass ihr
jetzt die bose neuen mixa gibt und sie
dort erst mal klein mix dann erhaltet
ihr genau die gleiche etwas feinere
homogene masse
[Musik]
nach wenigen sekunden kommt dann auch
schon der frischkäse mit dazu der wird
dann noch mal mit gemixt damit es eine
schöne einheitliche masse bildet und
dann geht es auch schon weiter mit dem
formen um die pralinen zu formen nehme
ich mir immer einen guten teelöffel von
der biomasse und rolle sie dann mit den
händen in der handinnenfläche zu kugeln
ihr könnt sie auch noch ein bisschen an
feuchten dann klappt das ganze noch
besser
[Musik]
und wie schon gesagt könnt ihr auch die
weißen bonus austauschen und dann nimmt
er einfach die vollmilch - das
funktioniert genauso gut
dieser schritt ist jetzt ganz wichtig
für zwölf bis 15 minuten kommen sie
jetzt ins tiefkühlfach und die schön gut
durch gekühlte pralinen gebe ich jetzt
in die geschmolzene weiße kuvertüre die
gefrorenen kugeln gebe ich jetzt in die
geschmolzene weiße kuvertüre las sie
ganz kurz abtropfen und lege sie dann
auf mein backpapier
[Musik]
im gefrorenen zustand lassen sich die
kugeln wasser eintauchen und sie
behalten dadurch auch die formen lassen
sich dadurch auch viel besser
herausnehmen bitte bitte spart diesen
schritt also nicht aus friert die kugeln
vorher unbedingt ein
[Musik]
sobald alle bueno kugeln dann mit der
ouvertüre überzogen wurden sind die
kugeln auch schon fertig ihr müsst sie
natürlich noch auskühlen lassen
austrocknen lassen
und ich gebe hier noch ein wenig bei
kakao drauf weil ich das optisch einfach
schöner finde das ist natürlich wieder
mal völlig optional oder ihr könntet
auch zum beispiel streusel nehmen oder
das was euch am liebsten gefällt
[Musik]
die pralinen sind tatsächlich
geschmacklich wie eine verbesserte
version der kinderpornos ich weiß ist es
kaum möglich den kinderbonus schmecken
an sicher schon so lecker aber probiert
die pralinen unbedingt mal aus wenn ihr
bueno fans seid ihr braucht wenig
zutaten ihr habt wenig aufwand und doch
ein so hübsches ergebnis falls ihr
keines meiner videos mehr verpassen
möchte dann hinterlasst mir doch gerne
ein abo und ich sag bis zum nächsten mal
auf die spitzenteams